Sara, long time no see.
Hi! Your sister looked beautiful.
Oh, thanks! You too. You know, you look like you've lost a ton of weight.
Do you see that girl over there with the brown hair?
Really high-maintenance.
That's my fiancee.
Hey, Aunt Kay!
Hey, it's Barbara.
Oh, right. Sorry. Yeah, Kay was my Uncle Bill's second wife.
Yes, I know that.
Sorry.
Can I have your attention? Can I have everyone's attention, please?
I'd like to say a few words about my sister.
Oh, no.
Well, I'm not really very good at this kind of thing but here it goes.
Oh, this is gonna be good.
Angie,...
...you've been blessed to find someone you can move through this life with.
Together, you've learned that love doesn't just happen.
You have to create it, craft it, and nurture it.
It can be even better when it's been held in the palm of the hand...
...and cradled for a while.
You've grown a love that is enduring,...
...stunning in its beauty.
Congratulations on your wedding and continuing to create your lives together.
I didn't actually write those words...
...but I do mean them.
I love you, Angie.
That was beautiful, Chris.
Now, eat up everyone, my mom paid like two grand for that cake.